이제 두 번째 함의를 살펴봐요. 이번에는 두 요건을 만족한다고 가정하는 사상의 Choi 표현에서 시작하고,
목표는 이 사상에 대한 Kraus 표현을 찾는 거예요. 앞서 이야기한 요건을 만족하는 거죠.
이 함의는 어떤 의미에서 꽤 기계적이에요. 약간의 선형 대수가 필요하고,
주로 행렬과 벡터를 꽤 영리한 방식으로 조작하는 걸로 귀결돼요.
Choi 표현이 양의 반정치라는 가정에서 시작하는데, 이게 우리가 가정하고 있는 두 요건 중 첫 번째예요.
양의 반정치 행렬의 개념은 양자 정보에서 근본적으로 중요해요. 밀도 행렬의 맥락에서만이 아니에요.
이게 없으면 이걸 작동시킬 수 없을 정도로 절대적으로 중요해요. 특히 J_Φ가
양의 반정치라는 가정은 화면에 표시된 형태로 표현할 수 있게 해줘요. 어떤
벡터 s_0부터 s_의 선택과 어떤 양의 정수 n의 선택으로요. 이것들이 반드시
단위 벡터일 필요는 없다는 걸 명시적으로 언급할게요. 이런 형태의 표현을 얻는 한 가지 방법은 양의 반정치 행렬에 대한 스펙트럼 정리에서 오는데,
이전 강의에서 논의했어요. 여기서는 스펙트럼 분해에서처럼 고유값이 명시적으로 나타나지 않지만,
양의 반정치 행렬의 고유값은 항상 비음수 실수라는 걸 기억하세요. 또한 이 벡터 s_0부터 s_이
단위 벡터일 필요가 없다는 것도 기억하세요. 그래서 할 수 있는 건 고유값의 제곱근을 취하고
스펙트럼 분해에서 얻는 단위 고유벡터에 곱해서 이
벡터 s_0부터 s_을 얻는 거예요. 실제로 이 증명에서 이 벡터들이 직교할 필요는 없어요.
스펙트럼 분해에서는 그게 나오지만, 여기서는 사용하지 않을 거예요. 스펙트럼 정리에서 오지 않은 J_Φ의 다른 표현이 있더라도
괜찮아요. 이제 화면에 표시된 것처럼 이 벡터들 각각을 분해하는데,
이건 이 벡터들이 시스템 쌍 XY의 양자 상태 벡터이고 X 시스템에 대해 표준 기저 측정을 수행하는 것처럼 하는 거예요.
명확히 말씀드리면, 여기서 아무것도 측정하지 않아요. 항상 가능한 이 형태로 벡터를 쓰는 것뿐이에요.
이제 트릭이 나와요. Kraus 행렬 a_0부터 a_을 정의하는데, 벡터 s_0부터 s_의 앞에서 K
A를 뽑아내고 뒤집어서 bra A가 되게 한 다음 화면의 방정식에 표시된 것처럼 오른쪽에 붙여요.
이걸 생각하는 한 가지 방법은 기본적으로 이 벡터들을 접어서 행렬로 만드는 거예요. A_K의 열들을 서로 위에 쌓으면
s_k를 다시 얻게 돼요. 이 행렬들은 대응하는 벡터와 정확히 같은 항목들을 가지고 있지만,
행렬을 얻도록 항목들을 다르게 재배열했을 뿐이에요. 또한 이 행렬들을 직접 표기법으로 순수하게 기호적으로 생각할 수도 있어요.
여기에 쓰여진 것처럼요. 이제 이 시점에서 명백한 질문이 있어요. 왜 이게 작동할까요? 왜 작동하는지에 너무 오래 머무르지 말고
그냥 작동하는지 확인해 봐요. 이를 위해 이 행렬들로 정의되는 새로운 사상을 정의해요.
Kraus 행렬로 처리해서요. 이제 할 수 있는 건 이
새로운 사상의 Choi 표현을 계산하는 거예요. 그러면 시작했던 사상 Φ의 Choi 표현과 같다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
그리고 Choi 표현이 충실하기 때문에, 이는 두 사상이 실제로 같다는 의미예요.
이 영상에서 대수를 다루지 않을 거예요. 직접 확인할 수 있는데, 꽤 기계적이고 좋은 연습이 돼요.
필요한 모든 것이 화면에 있어요.
두 번째 조건에 대해서는 아직 아무 말도 하지 않았지만,
두 조건이 동등하다는 것은 화면 하단에 표시된 방정식을 확인해서 알 수 있어요.
여기서 T는 행렬 전치를 가리키는데, 이는 |a⟩⟨b|를 |b⟩⟨a|로 바꾸는 선형 사상으로 생각할 수 있어요.
공식이 작동하게 만드는 데 필요한 거예요. 요약하면,
이 함의에는 분명히 약간의 대수가 필요하지만, 앞서 말했듯이 모두 꽤 기계적이에요.
기본적으로 인덱스 체조라고 어떤 이들이 부르는 거예요. 하지만 직접 해보고 머릿속에서 소화할 기회를 준다면,
Choi 표현과 Kraus 표현이 어떻게 관련되는지 더 잘 이해하게 될 거예요. 세 번째 함의는
사상 Φ의 Kraus 표현에서, 일반적인 조건이 있는 곳에서 Stinespring 표현으로 가는 거예요. 이건 꽤
이전 함의와 정신적으로 비슷해요. 기계적이고 순수하게 대수적인 용어로 볼 수 있고 확인할 수 있다는 의미에서요.
아이디어는 실제로 꽤 간단해요. 할 수 있는 건 Kraus 행렬들을 가져다가 화면에 표시된 것처럼 서로 위에 쌓아서 더 큰 행렬의 일부를 형성하는 거예요.
이것이 채워지면 Stinespring 표현의 unitary 행렬 U가 될 거예요.
unitary 행렬은 정방 행렬이어야 하므로, 그렇게 하기 위해 필요한 만큼의 나머지
열들을 채워야 해요. 하지만 unitary 행렬을 얻는 한 그것들이 무엇인지는 실제로 차이가 없어요.
U가 unitary라는 걱정을 잠시 제쳐두고 U 행렬에서 얻는 Stinespring 표현으로 정의되는 선형 사상에만 집중한다면,
사상이 시작했던 Kraus 표현으로 정의된 원래 사상 Φ와 같다는 걸 알게 돼요.
이건 이 영상에서 다루지 않을 증명의 또 다른 부분이에요. 이번 강의의 문서에서 세부 사항을 찾을 수 있지만,
직접 시간을 내서 해보고 싶을 수도 있어요. 항상 그렇듯이 시리즈에서
다이어그램을 해석할 때 ket 순서 규칙을 사용한다는 걸 기억하세요. 그래서 W와 G는 방정식에서 왼쪽의 텐서 인수에 해당해요.
그리고 직접 해본다면, 방정식에서 왼쪽의 텐서 인수로 |0⟩⟨0|가 있기 때문에
U에서 관련 있는 유일한 부분은 Kraus 행렬들로 주어지는 부분이라는 걸 알게 될 거예요.
U의 열들을 unitary가 되도록 채우기만 하면 되지만, 이는 a_0부터 a_로 형성된 열들이
서로 위에 쌓았을 때 정규직교해야 한다는 것을 요구해요. 여기서 Kraus 표현에 두는 조건이 중요해져요.
실제로 이 조건은 열들이 정규직교하다는 것과 정확히 동등해요. 이 결론을 도출하는 데 필요한 관련 수학적 관계들이
화면 하단에 표시돼 있어요. 잠깐 멈추고 확인해 보거나,
더 자세한 내용은 문서를 참조하세요. 간단히 말하면, 이 함의와 이전 함의에서 일어나고 있는 일은
같은 수학적 연산을 다르지만 동등한 방식으로 설명하고 있다는 거예요.
이 모든 것의 핵심은 본질적으로 행렬 곱셈이에요. 네 번째이자 마지막 함의는 사상에 대한
Stinespring 표현이 있으면 그 사상이 실제로 유효한 채널이어야 한다는 걸 확립해요.
앞서 언급했듯이, Stinespring 표현을 논의할 때 이미 이 함의를 다뤘어요.
요약하면,